at this point she's not doing a very
good job because she's about to get
killed she's not giving up any
information what she should actually do
is try and craft some kind of a story
that stalls or prolongs her life
hey this is Jocko willing I'm sitting in
my podcast studio remotely and this is
the breakdown first up is Saving Private
Ryan
obviously this scene is d-day the
military really looked to bring a lot of
people that didn't have combat
experience to do the invasion on d-day
because they knew that they needed some
fresh mindsets going in that weren't
going to be absolutely horrified but
even with that you can tell from this
that there's a lot of fear going on
because they're going into a pretty
hellacious situation
you can see a lot of the guys are
looking very nervous they're trying to
capture that on the camera you see some
of the guys that are actually throwing
up and they could be throwing up from
being nervous that can't happen but my
guess is in this case most of these guys
are throwing up because they're seasick
they're not used to being on the water
and they're going through rough seas
your body starts to adapt to the motion
of the ocean when you spend a lot of
time on the water in boats but even
going from a large ship which these guys
have been on into smaller boats people
that aren't used to it they can
definitely get seasick and that's
probably what's going on here in a navy
vessel starboard side is as you're
looking forward in the vessel it's the
right hand side the port side is the
left hand side so he's saying the stick
which is just a group of people that are
on the starboard side he's just given
them instructions United States military
is made up of multiple different
branches you have the Army Navy Air
Force Marine Corps in this scene right
here you see Navy boats that are
bringing US Army soldiers to the shore
as soon as they hit the shore they're
going to be doing what the army does
while they're in the water they're doing
what the Navy does you have to have a
good relationship between the services
in order to get the job done and they
certainly are showing that here five men
he's talking about right there he's
saying keep your dispersion is what we
call it means space yourselves out don't
bunch up in a group if you're all
together in a tight group you become an
easy target for the enemy because they
don't have to shoot very accurately and
they'll hit one of you if you're in a
group they shoot a burst of ammunition
they could take out three four or five
guys that are in that group what that
sergeant is telling them is to keep your
distance from each other so you make
yourselves harder targets most of times
we need to do some kind of an amphibious
operation coming over the beach you're
gonna get wet there's a chance that you
could possibly stay dry but it's a
pretty small chance it's one of the
things that makes coming over the beach
and amphibious operations so hard not
only does it make you cold but it
affects your gear your radios your
weapons everything gets affected
especially by saltwater it's a real
challenge and it's something you have to
contend with because it's gonna happen
one of the things that makes Saving
Private Ryan so realistic is that it
doesn't shy away from showing the
horrific graphic nature of war war is
absolutely violence it's killing and
it's death maiming human beings and it
shows that really without any mercy in
this opening scene this is actually a
nightmare scenario coming across an open
area which starts with the water and
then goes onto the beach and you're
facing elevated machine-gun positions
from the enemy they're shooting down at
you from a totally protected position so
what are you doing a situation like that
how do you face that well what you have
to do and it's very counterintuitive is
you have to move forward as a leader or
as just one of these troops that's out
there trying to survive this situation
you might think I just want to stay here
and hide I did I don't want to move but
what you have to do is move and what
that also means is if you are with one
of your friends and they get hit you
might not be able to help them and the
best thing you can possibly do for them
is to continue to advance that's what
makes this scene so hard to watch guys
are having to at that moment make a
decision between staying with their
friend and dying together or moving
forward to try and accomplish the
mission it's a horrible situation to be
in
the Navy had units that would go in to
the beach and clear out obstacles it
also go and try and clear out obstacles
that were in the water on the beach
before the invasion even starts the
predecessors to the SEAL Teams were
those guys on underwater demolition
units and if you really want to get
specific about it in the Battle of
Tarawa over in the Pacific
there was a operation that took place
where the Marine Corps was taking that
island and they hit a bunch of
underwater reefs with the boats and the
boats got held up on those reefs and so
the Marines had to get out and they had
to go across about 600 yards of water
before they got to the beach and they
took massive casualties it was a
horrendous scene in the US military the
Navy and the Marine Corps realized that
we needed to have someone that could
figure out what was under the water as
they got close to the beach and if there
was obstacles there than to get rid of
them and so they formed up the Navy
combat demolition units and those were
the guys that eventually became the
underwater demolition teams and those
are the guys that eventually became the
SEAL Teams the most important things
about the US military and any good
military organization is that they use
something called decentralized command
there's not some senior person at the
top of the rank structure making every
single decision for the people on the
frontlines the people on the frontlines
understand what it is that they're
supposed to get done and then they go
and do it by any means that they see fit
so sometimes there might be a little
conflict but as you can see Tom Hanks's
character they have a little bit of a
discussion but it lasts two sentences
and then they move on and go and try and
achieve the objective that's
decentralized command and you see it in
action there this scene depicts the
incredible bravery that these soldiers
had to storm forward facing a high
percentage chance of them being killed
or gravely wounded this is one of those
epic battle scenes that again reflects
the courage of the frontline soldiers
next up we have Apocalypse Now
[Music]
the premise of this movie is that
there's a guy Colonel Kurtz that has
gone native gone rogue and the US
military decides that he needs to be
taken out and so they send a Special
Forces soldier along with a bunch of
Navy patrol boat personnel up to go and
kill them this is a movie having someone
go completely rogue like that is pretty
unrealistic it would get picked up on
and they'd be taken out of that
situation and put into some place where
they could recover and get a grip on
reality again one of the things that was
unique about Vietnam was the river
system that were flowed throughout the
country in the Mekong Delta in other
areas you know they had what we called
the brown water Navy the predecessor to
the Special Boat teams which we now have
was guys driving small boats that could
push up into these enemy controlled
areas and conduct operations and that's
pretty much what is taking place in
Apocalypse Now they've got a chief petty
officer in charge of this vessel a chief
petty officer in the Navy is a very
proud rank they say in the Navy that
Chiefs run the Navy Navy Chiefs are very
experienced tactically they understand
what the job is and they do what they
need to do to get the job done
[Music]
you might be wondering well these guys
are out on patrol they seem to be joking
around they seem to be carefree you got
to remember that anyone in the military
SEALs included we're just people and
people have lives and they've got
girlfriends back home and they've got
other things going on and they want to
laugh and have a good time you know this
would be obviously tactically unsound to
light off a purple smoke and give your
position away to the enemy and actually
obscure the vision of the people that
are on the boat that's a little bit
unrealistic but for the fact that they
are sort of relaxed because there's no
actual combat taking place that can
happen now depending on where you are
you need to use caution and it certainly
seems that in this scene they've allowed
a little bit too much slack and they're
about to get a rude awakening it's an
ambush what you see kind of looks like
fireworks and I think in fact they
probably are fireworks I think what
they're trying to simulate is tracer
fire bullets that leave glowing red or
glowing green in the air when they shoot
it's a little unrealistic because you
can tell that they don't have a lot of
velocity when tracer rounds are coming
at you they're moving a lot faster than
these but I think that's just the
limitations of special effects for this
scene
and then what you see is the reaction
from the boat which is a pretty standard
reaction what they do is as quickly as
possible return a heavy volume of fire
from their machine guns and try and move
the boat out of the kill zone which is
the area of the ambush where if you stay
there
you're gonna die as far as the weapons
that they're using they're pretty
standard vietnam-era
weapons they've got some m60 machine
guns they've got a dual mounted 50
caliber machine gun and they've got m16s
that's what they used in Vietnam for
sure the Vietnam War from the SEAL team
perspective is those are the guys that
really establish the reputation of the
SEAL Teams by the operations that they
conducted they just did an outstanding
job taking the fight to the enemy in a
very unconventional way the seals that
raised me in the SEAL Teams some of them
were the old Vietnam guys and that was
an honor to be able to learn from them
next GI Jane the premise of this movie
is that there is a female that is going
through SEAL training that has not
happened before it looks like what they
are attempting to portray is some kind
of seer training which is survival
evasion resistance and escape and it's
training in case you're ever captured by
the enemy in a time of war they start
with being woken up with water being
thrown honor when you go to sere school
you're definitely going to experience
all kinds of little minor aggravations
just being in a seal platoon you're
gonna get woken up by your buddies with
water being thrown on you so that's
something that everyone's going to
experience they're trying to torment you
mentally for two reasons one to make
sure that you can kind of deal with the
mental frustration of people bothering
you and two because it's funny what is
your father's name
simple question lieutenant no reason not
to answer unless you want to bleed what
is your father's name dad they're
showing her in a situation where she's
being tied up as if she was a prisoner
of war that's what they're trying to
simulate and then you know they're gonna
try and mimic what they think the
prisoner of war might experience you
know in sere school you're gonna be
hungry you're gonna get slapped around
you're gonna asked a bunch of questions
in order to try and prepare you for
those situations should they unfold why
didn't you go yeah you wounded
lieutenant was it too heavy it looks
like the Master Chief is really being
pretty brutal with a beatdown
to the young lieutenant and I think it's
just a lot of Hollywood activities going
on there are limitations to what they
can do to the students that are going
through it but it's best for the
training if people don't know what to
expect when they get there so I actually
don't want to talk too much in detail
about it because it's an experience that
hits people different ways the training
is based on lessons learned from guys
that were captured in Korea and Vietnam
and what they learned from those
horrible environments I'll just say that
this movie doesn't seem very realistic
go easy on women
at this point it seems like they've got
a little crazy sometimes they portray
things a different way but you know the
the SEAL Teams is a rough place to be
beating a seal platoon or out of SEAL
team or in the military in general it's
a it's a harsh environment harsh things
happen you might think that there's a
technique to get through something like
waterboarding but the bottom line is
there's no technique for not being able
to breathe you can breath hold for a
little while maybe two minutes maybe
three minutes but eventually you're
gonna need air and you're gonna pass out
it's just another method of making you
uncomfortable and trying to get you used
to being uncomfortable and they're also
trying to show you that you have
limitations eventually what you have to
do is give some information so you can
survive and that's acceptable and you do
your best to resist and not give away
information that could cost the lives of
fellow service members but you also want
to survive and so that's a tough bridge
to gap one of the things that happened
in previous wars is people felt like if
they had broken that they were less of a
man for breaking everyone has a breaking
point and you need to understand how to
contend with that psychologically you
got some Toby at this point she's not
doing a very good job because she's
about to get killed she's not giving up
any information what she should actually
do is try and craft some kind of a story
that stalls or prolongs her life the
goal is to give enough information that
you survive but not enough information
that the enemy can actually act and if
you're giving a little bit of
information they think they can get more
out of you then you can stay alive a
little bit longer and hopefully make it
out NASA chief seek life elsewhere
[Music]
[Applause]
in the SEAL Teams you go through a lot
of different schools and you pass a lot
of different tests when you get done
with one test what you do is you go on
to the next one you finish that
achievement and you move on there's no
big celebration of making it through
some block of training you just carry on
and do your job
Navy SEALs describe your method of entry
came through a skylight and you had
contact in the hallway one concurrently
when you get done' with a mission you
want to review how the mission went from
a tactical perspective and see if there
are any lessons learned no one's gonna
remember every little thing that they
did but hopefully when you take all the
information from all the different
individuals you can paint a pretty good
picture of what happened and once you
get done with that then you do a
intelligence debrief to make sure you've
gathered good information and that
information will then get disseminated
through the intelligence community so
that they can put all the pieces of
intelligence together to get broader
knowledge of the enemy there are actions
that the objective area under the room
in this third position
would love to run when you go into a
room obviously you all can't go into the
room at the exact same moment so the
first person goes in that's the number
one person the second person that goes
in is the number two person the third
person that goes in is the number three
person it goes right on down the line so
that's all it is there's no rocket
science there and then he did a normal
room entry and swept from left to right
so pilot had serious internal injuries i
stabilized him prepared to move
that's good at the fan the primary LZ
was aborted I covered their movement to
the secondary the primary LZ is the
primary landing zone if you're taking
down a target or you're conducting an
operation when you leave you're gonna go
get picked up somewhere the first place
you plan to go get picked up by
helicopters is called the primary
landing zone and if that one is fouled
for whatever reason there's enemy there
or there's some problem with it then
you'll move on to the secondary and then
if that one's got a problem you'll move
on to the tertiary so in this particular
scene they tried to go to the primary
landing zone LZ and there was a problem
with it so they apparently moved to the
secondary you engage hustles I'm
vaporize hostiles when you're in the
military you follow the rules of
engagement and rules of engagement do
shift depending on the situation the
rules of engagement definitely allow you
to defend yourself and the mission if
you shoot your weapon and somebody
that's acting in a hostile manner it's
really no factor oh by the way thanks
for the hot tip on 100 [ __ ] we in
Canada you're soft targets make sure
wonder why they call it and tell us when
he's describing a soft target that's
generally a description of a target that
you think is gonna be pretty easy to
take down meaning there's not gonna be a
lot of resistance whereas a hard target
would you'd be expecting resistance and
maybe some fortified positions
regardless soft target or hard target
you got to prepare for some kind of a
worst-case scenario you gotta have
contingencies to handle on any target
even if you go in thinking it's gonna be
soft
it could go hard you have to anticipate
that it could that was just the
breakdown from GQ thanks for watching